For an exponential function of the form f of x equals a to the x,
we know that a must be greater than 0, and a cannot equal 1.
Now, since logarithmic functions are the inverses of exponential functions,
the same must be true for the base of a log. That means that this choice,
all positive real numbers except 1, is correct. The positive real
numbers are the numbers greater than 0, and if you don't include 1,
that means that they can't equal 1. Remember that if we let a equal 1 and
see what happens we end up with a function f of x equals 1 to the x.
This is just equal to 1, which means it's just a horizontal line.
This doesn't pass the horizontal line test. So that means that
this exponential function doesn't have an inverse. In other words,
if we let a equal 1, then there's no logarithmic function that can come out of
this exponential function. The same is true if you decide to let a equal 0.
So bottom line, they're both logs and exponents, the base of it,
which I've written as a, must be positive and it can't equal 1.